hot breath and you're great at finding
like comparisons and contrasts
like ah thanks i i'm a big analogy guy
because yeah
i think in analogies that's why i'm so
bad at math i'm horrible at math
but uh i'm a big analogy guy because i
don't think anything conveys a point
as well as an analogy and i have a weird
so i'll throw a weird idea at you and
the audience goes huh
but then i throw the analogy at you and
you go all right now i get it
so i think that's why i do it like your
colbert set you have a joke
about how um we can't cure hangovers
or we can't prevent hangovers we can
prevent kids yes and then you take it
into
how um like you're not honest drunk
you're actually honest when you have a
hangover yes
like how did that kind of start and grow
into that uh that was a weird one
the kids thing like i always used to say
isn't it weird we can't prevent a
hangover and everybody goes yeah yeah
whatever and i'm like
oh hang on this is where the analogy
comes in i go
but we can prevent children we figure
that out and people go
oh yeah that's true we can prevent
children but we can't write a hangover
now i see why your point holds water so
i have to throw that in there just so
people go oh
i get where you're coming from now and
then the hangover thing is i'm hungover
all the time and i've always thought
people would say like oh this guy's such
a bad drunk and he's he's got to quit
drinking and i'm like i'm fine drunk
i can drink and drive i can drink and
have a conversation i'm not like a
blackout guy really
but when i'm hungover i'm the i'm a mess
and i was
like the hang i'm i'm a i have a
hangover problem not a drinking problem
you know so that that i realized that
and i was like all right well
maybe there's a bit here and then that
came into that
so is it like when i'm hungover i can't
leave the house
my anxiety's through the roof i can't i
got a couch delivered
the other day when i was hungover and i
didn't answer the door so these these
movers are at my home
with a couch outside my door buzzing
and i just couldn't do it i couldn't
answer the door because i was too
anxiety riddled i was too [ __ ]
nervous and weird i couldn't do it so i
never got the couch
so i was about it was good to hear you
got furniture no no couch
still no couch well with the with the
we can prevent kids but not hangovers
did it start off as
we can't prevent hangovers and then you
have you just tried to riff on a bunch
of different examples and the kids
weren't
stuck or did it immediately uh well
the kids one is is good because it's
such an extreme
you know like i need something that
really like grabs you like they might
say oh we can prevent
uh termites you're like yeah yeah but
you're like we can prevent kids
and then you think abortion and like you
think birth control it's it's a
it's a heavier example and i think
that's why i went with it